[Music]
good afternoon John it is Thursday
January 11 so I was just watching my
video from January 9th I'm paying the
price for not being commensurate with my
values at some point while in Detroit I
met a really like a tiny chicken I don't
actually remember this tiny chicken but
I'm almost positive that we had an
encounter because this tiny chicken has
laid tiny eggs in my head one here one
here one here and one here those tiny
eggs are growing and hatching and the
baby tiny chickens are feeding on my
brain they do everything that baby
chickens do they're cute they're fuzzy
they poop and they eat they're eating my
brain and their poop is coming out my
nose chicken
top if you see junk coming out of my
toes because it'd be really embarrassing
to have that caught up video blog no
it's still there ah there we go ha no
junk no junk coming out my nose no I
think that we should suggest some more
punishments so that we can choose
between punishments also we can have
people suggest punishments so far all we
have is the 500 miles punishment which
I'd be totally okay with doing honestly
I think it'd be fun
so punishments I'm suggesting today grow
your facial hair for one full week and
then wax your chin also there's the
stick a needle in my eye provision third
on my list of punishments that I'm
suggesting for today give yourself a
mohawk I've kind of always wanted to get
myself a mohawk and I'd really like an
excuse I've got a little bit of a
problem and I was hoping that you or
maybe one of our viewers could help me
out I was going to Detroit right so I
figured I'd have a bunch of business
cards printed up I used an online
service
I uploaded my files and they sent me a
bunch of business cards I like that I
like like a nice dirty card stock and on
the back it supposed to be like this one
which I got printed off at Kinkos this
one on the back says this and on the
front says this what am I supposed to do
with this okay it's one thing to have
one that does that about this many this
many that are the same on all the sides
what am I supposed to do with it John
viewers what do I do with 103 inch by
one and a half inch cards
that's a ego geek on them so far my only
idea is to tape them all over my face I
would walk 500 miles and I would walk
500 ball see this is there's a to me not
a punishment not I don't know to me it's
not a punishment please need to come
with better punishments is what I'm
saying